this podcast is brought to you by secret
society this is of course for those of
you who don't know a clothing line that
I have been a part of for almost three
years strong you know for us we love
contemporary fashion basics but a lot of
companies that sell them don't provide
the quality that comes with it and you
know those brands that slap on a logo
that make you feel like you got to be a
certain somebody to rocket or if it's
dirt cheap you know that your clothing
is gonna fall apart after like one wash
and we're really not about that secret
society is dope
high-quality contemporary street wear
that I rock on a regular basis because
it feels and it looks good so listen up
all genius brain listeners will get 15%
off all first orders and all you have to
do is just type in the code brain at
checkout to get your 15% off that secret
society my friend s C R T s o CI e py
dot-com and enter brain to get your 15%
off your first order today once again
that's s c RT s o CI e py comm yeah I'm
good yeah you know what I'm just I'm not
to admit something I've never admitted
before okay okay
you gonna [ __ ] you're gonna go to lose
a lot of respect for me lose a lot of
respect at me or you're gonna respect me
alone okay so when I was going to break
up with her at this point I had already
cemented it cemented in my heart that
she wasn't the one for me and I was okay
with it
yes yeah so when I told her like it was
over I could hear her kind of crying on
the other end
I felt so bad of her because I didn't
feel anything I sort of faked crying for
her fake crying fur in five four three
two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast
what is he Russian I don't know I don't
know what I thought he was Asian but
it's like people still watch The
Simpsons
that [ __ ] was our childhood but the
thing is it's like I don't know if
you've watched any of the more
relatively newer episodes it's changed
so much like because the thing is once
Family Guy started really popping off I
think they had to kind of try to keep up
with their type of sense of humor okay
and so it ended up becoming like super
random and not to say The Simpsons
wasn't random before but you could tell
that their their jokes kind of changed
you know a sense of humor kind of
changed so it wasn't like when you watch
the classic Simpsons like let's say
seasons 1 through like 15 or something
you know you'll notice a difference
between that and then the Simpsons as of
like the past I don't know five years
six years yeah yeah it's very different
when I used to watch The Simpsons I
remember I couldn't wait to watch the
Halloween special Christmas treehouse of
horror dude Halloween specials were that
was the [ __ ] best hands down and
that's what I mean this is before like
the Hulu days and everything else but we
would have to look forward to these yeah
yeah yeah every year I'm like it's
Halloween yeah I know I'm gonna get a
special yeah
Simpsons episode whatever TV show that
you're watching you were gonna get a
special Halloween episode so [ __ ]
dope okay I have a Disney Plus so I
actually watched those Treehouse of
Horror episode early yeah I'm like dude
I remember these classics I want to go
and revisit them and I watch it and so
like takes me back dude it's like a
[ __ ] time capsule man and watch the
Hamilton Hamilton I haven't I haven't
the Hamilton like dope I'm not I'm not
even like super into musicals but
Hamilton is [ __ ] dope man that's all
I've been singing around the house
Muriel's [ __ ] irritated [ __ ] I'm
gonna keep singing but she loves it too
though she loves it yeah that's
something I've been meaning to check out
just cuz like you know everybody's
talking about it
anybody who says they haven't watched
Hamilton how much you hate black people
do that's why racist polarizing like
black people use [ __ ] Hamilton's amazing
[ __ ] a speaking of a prominent black
people though [ __ ] the Smiths are in
trouble dude what happened so you do you
know about this [ __ ] I you got to tell
me I don't really keep up with too many
things right I'm trying to now just
because you know we had this podcast and
there are certain things that people
want me to talk about right which I'm
completely fine doing in money these are
all loose opinions but so apparently so
you do you remember this rumor back in
the day where people started up that
that Will Smith and Jada Pinkett Smith
were going through some [ __ ] and then
they were in an open relationship well I
guess before on the red tabletalk before
they talked that they didn't have an
open relationship well during that time
that people were speculated that they
were split up they actually were split
up they went through a separation period
they were legally divorced yeah but they
didn't talk about the specificities but
on the red tabletalk which his Jada
pinkett-smith show yeah she had will on
where she basically told them about a
relationship that she had with another
man okay August Alsina
your [ __ ] August I'll seen in the R&B
singer right no I don't know if you hear
a couple of tracks you know who I'll
guess I'll seen it uh-huh
she had a relationship with him and the
reason why they found this out is
because August Alsina was doing the
radio radio interview I forgot which one
it was
I don't think it's a Breakfast Club it
could have been but he talked about a
past relationship that he had with Janet
Pinkett Smith by name by name oh my
[ __ ] name right Will and Jada Pinkett
Smith have been together since like 1991
or 1997 yeah I can't remember yeah but
since the 90 so people are like wait
hold up how the [ __ ] could you be with
Jada Pinkett Smith when August Alsina is
in his 20s yeah and he's actually Jayden
Smith's friend which is how she actually
met August Alsina to her son he's super
[ __ ] young cuz Jada pinkett-smith is
51 years old I believe she's in her 50s
uh-huh so they're like wait how could
you be with Jada if they've been
together since the 90s that doesn't make
any [ __ ] sense you're like oh Jada
Pinkett Smith cheated on Will Smith
uh-huh
and this is kind of how this
relationship started circular other
people can correct me if I'm wrong I
read this a couple of times I'm not too
solid on this but that's kind of where
it all started out where these rumors
started coming out so they addressed it
on the read table talk show or she
talked about she as she called it if you
watch the video clip she goes it was an
entanglement
am i you mean entanglement but would you
these euphemisms even what was like
entanglement will you mean like you were
with him right but they were separated
and so on the radio show even August
Alsina says like Will Smith gave him
permission right which he did not he did
not give you [ __ ] permission guy mr.
Smith can I like come on bro but August
Alsina but you know Will Smith or even
Jada Pinkett Smith wanted to correct
there he goes there's nobody that can
give somebody permission over me and I
can only do that right right so well you
know and it's funny when you watch that
video clip will exfol he looks like it's
tough this happened a few years ago too
this doesn't happen recently
okay so this stuff that they've already
dealt with and their marriage is fine
now but even bringing it up you can look
at Will Smith and like he's already you
could tell like just the conversation
topic kind of irritates him well it's
not exactly the most personal business
that was put out not even to their own
volition it was [ __ ] August all seem
to decide to flap his [ __ ] gums about
it and so what what I kind of researched
and found out was number one I don't
know [ __ ] about this dude right so they
actually met each other through Jaden
Smith her [ __ ] son that's the worst
part about and he's super young I think
he's still in his 20s but he met her at
a time where both of them were very
broken human beings Jaden Jada Pinkett
Smith and Will Smith weren't having a
great relationship yeah they were going
through their own stuff and they were
kind of elusive about what they were
going through but he was basically
saying like you had to figure your [ __ ]
out I had to figure out my [ __ ] and so
while they were separated August Alsina
came into the law came into our life and
he was very broken - so he had some [ __ ]
with his with his liver that went
[ __ ] bad there was a chance that he
was gonna be a paraplegic or something
gonna walk again
he went blind in one of his eye and I
think recently his mom passed oh it's
the whole bunch of [ __ ] dude he's
basically job from the Bible he's [ __ ]
Joe and so in this she kind of found
comfort in him and so was she where she
basically expressed at the red tabletalk
she was saying that she figured
that she had a problem that she likes
being with broken people that she finds
an attraction in somebody that she feels
like she could fix and that's where she
found a lot of comfort in and so you
could tell August Alsina still has
feelings for her or whatever I mean they
called it quits but that should blew the
[ __ ] up she kept on using war just like
entanglement entanglement I had an
entanglement like these euphemisms man
come on entanglement you had an affair I
guess they were separated and even
willsez they were separated but I think
the the thing that kind of took online
that people were kind of saying was
there's a double standard right when
people kind of look at it as if this was
the other way around where Will Smith
was with a girl who went through who had
a lot of mental problems and a lot of
mental issues and he found cover and
they they hooked up or they were taking
advantage they would say that he took
advantage of her and so I think on
Twitter and I and I was reading on a
couple of forums they were kind of
saying that Jada Pinkett Smith took
advantage of August Alsina mm-hmm that
in a time of weakness she kind of used
her power or whatever it was whatever
she found attractive they said that you
know she took advantage of a guy who was
mentally unstable mm-hmm so that's
that's kind of the whole thing that's
going on right there and I personally
don't know how to feel about this [ __ ]
and it's not really my business they
figured out what they were doing right
and even watching that read Table Talk
was super [ __ ] awkward because I
think like even bringing it up you could
tell Will Smith this is a little salty I
won't be [ __ ] salty right well I mean
it's the thing is if he's 20-something
now then how old was he when they were
having me who's super young 20s or
something like that okay I mean you guys
can look it up I'll put it probably put
it in the video yeah that Jess that's
cuz look man Jada pinkett-smith at that
point is a grown-ass woman
you know she's a grown-ass full well not
full life experience but good life
experience for sure adult whereas this
guy he's still a kid you know yes by a
legal standards he's an adult but not by
life experience you know so he's still
learning and he's still he's still
becoming his own person so in that
scenario I would say the blame falls
more on
ADA's laugh just because she should be
more aware you know and look it's like
to each their own everybody has their
cup of tea but like just did cheer hCAP
it's like how do you relate to somebody
on an intellectual level ma yeah I mean
like well no no I mean the other way
around for Jada were like what is well
for her she said that she kind of she
realized that she had a problem of
trying to be with broken people and
trying to flow so her thing was just I
want to fix this boy yeah well I forgot
what that there's a phrase or term for
people like that right which I see a lot
of people in and I think I've even been
in a relationship where I could tell
just from the the habits that this girl
had with her previous boyfriends that
she had before she specifically were she
was with people that she felt that she
could fix and I was one of her pet
projects and I think the problem with
that
and I actually I know the problem with
that is that broken people trying to fix
another broken person doesn't ever
[ __ ] work yeah right you got a lot of
your own personal issues that you have
to deal with it deal with and your what
you're really doing is you're deflecting
a lot of the stuff that you have to fix
and you feel that in the process of you
helping somebody else that there's a
couple of things that happen you feel
like in the process of you helping
somebody else out you're healing
yourself as well and really you're not
you're not and the second thing that I
really believe that happens is that when
you when you become the catalyst for
somebody else's positive change it
almost makes you feel like you're not a
broken human being now right you say
well if I'm helping this person out yeah
I guess I'm really not that bad off yeah
but the only thing that you're doing
you're [ __ ] lying to yourself right
and then what happens when that person
is fixed where are you now you're your
definition and your meaning of a
meaningful relationship was you fixing
this person well guess what this person
is now fixed yeah so where are you at in
your [ __ ] relationship and I think
for her good thing she did realize that
and even for him he's a broken human
being and he's trying to have somebody
else fix him and I don't know what he
personally went through but it seems
like he was going through a lot going
blind he couldn't walk again
there's you you that stuff come from I
was a serial killer this is what you get
but I don't know what the [ __ ] happened
but he had like some kind of like some
kind of medical condition that was gonna
affect him walking uh-huh and I I was
reading all the [ __ ] that was going on
in his life and I'm like [ __ ] I'd be
depressed too [ __ ] man yeah um but you
know for him and I'm trying to think of
myself as a young man who was with
somebody who was trying to fix me it's
almost like you kind of define who you
are as a human being based on what
somebody else says you are and he's not
really taking the time to really fix
himself yeah and I think he still really
[ __ ] up because I think only in 2018
or so his mom passed away - hmm so this
[ __ ] can't catch up right yeah I
mean the thing is though right is that
it's it's all fine and good to have like
a support community around you who like
helps you out right but in terms of
using the word fix right how is a non
trained person gonna have the tools
necessary in order to really know what's
going on to dig into these issues and
help a person address those issues in a
healthy manner right yeah you don't have
the tools because you didn't study it
you're not a [ __ ] doctor in this
field right what we're talking about
mental issues that's not visible it's
not like a cut on your knee that you can
visibly fix right you got to do some
digging
to find out what the root causes are of
all of these issues that this person is
going through why it's making them feel
the way they feel why it's making them
think what they think and it's it's it's
a process and then so like somebody to
come in and talk about fixing people
when you don't have the credentials for
it when you're not a doctor
by any means so what are you using what
are you using as your baseline to like
gauge how you're doing you know [ __ ]
suck the paint on his dick
that is only temporary my friend yeah
exactly it's it I wouldn't call that
chicks and to be with a younger man I
don't [ __ ] know I don't know what's
going on
I feel like celebrities too they're
always in some weird [ __ ] for sure man
dude think about like the world that
they're living in where they have luxury
and freedom
that's not granted to most people in
this world not only are they wealthy
they've they're famous so they have
power as well do that cuz you know about
the whole Jeffrey Epstein right and I
guess recently something came out about
somebody her last name is Maxwell
jillaine yeah yeah did you read about
Lygia
yeah she's basically was his accomplice
the whole time she's a [ __ ] criminal
just as bad as he is
she she [ __ ] groomed these young
girls you know she was kind of like the
the initiator right because Jeffrey
Epstein was kind of like socially
awkward apparently and he wasn't as good
with talking to people so she would be
kind of like the soft you know big
sister or motherly type role that she
would play and talking to these young
girls come off very nice come off like
very caring and then that's your in you
get their trust once you have their
trust you start initiating him into
these little things first it starts with
a massage then Jeffrey Epstein buses
dicks out and the muscle a dick that
dick out in the massage then it turns
into oh I'm gonna send you to my friends
what do you think happens when that
happens yeah yeah yeah you know what I
mean so she she [ __ ] that she get out
of it is just she she liked that type of
[ __ ] it was not you got names man no no
she was his partner she was like yeah
she was Jeffrey Epstein's partner so
like that was like it's like Arthur
liked his partner like like a wife
without the title pretty mellow [ __ ]
yeah yeah so they were a couple they
were together and I don't know if like
Jeffrey Epstein had some kind of hold on
her like where he kind of brainwashed
her but obviously she has some [ __ ] up
issues in herself to look at what's
going on and to be completely okay with
it you know she was
the documentary right she was the one
that was she would be like it's okay
just kind of fall into it yeah I mean
she basically would not even like really
talk about it in that way it seemed like
if she just normalized everything yeah
you know like this nothing unusual is
going on here you know like this is this
is what it like work your life is gonna
be so much better because of because you
met us you know she's like everything
you want in life you want to be an
artist we'll send you to what does she
do for a living exactly that she was
connected to Jeffrey Epstein I know she
was like thoroughly connected to like
her family is highly connected like the
CIA or some [ __ ] I don't know I forget I
think they did mention what her family
background was but um yeah it either way
it's that she was just as she was
complicit you know she has they said
that she had she has videos or she said
that she has videos of high high end so
so that's that's I think that's what
people are worried about because when
Jeffrey Epstein's place was rated right
they recovered a lot of [ __ ] that he
stored away in a safe and all of that
the videos pictures and that's why
there's a big question mark about how
Jeffrey Epstein died they say he
committed suicide
he was killed yeah yeah so out of that I
mean this guy obviously had a lot of
[ __ ] over a very powerful people um yeah
what did a d'Alene have where I don't
know if Jelena or Gillian but yes so
they they confiscated all that stuff but
they this is the government right is the
government they haven't brought any of
these people in no that's because
they're gonna use that to control some
damning evidence in there you know big
sex well no so like with Bill Clinton
like he was seen on the island you know
countless times but one of the the
primary girls who was a victim in that
circumstance said you know Bill Clinton
never did anything like that was you
know an inappropriate or he is she never
saw him engage with like these minors he
would mod dicks
yeah armonica is good yes so uh that's
what she said now it doesn't mean that
he's innocent by any means but like if
some of these people are partaking in
those activities on on that island then
and he's been Bill Clinton was there
that many times chances are he was in
multiple time yeah yeah chance you was
there many times yeah so from what she
said she saw he was always like very
professional very kind never done
anything but what are you doing there
yeah that's the thing I don't know I
don't know like maybe maybe there was
just that friendship and he was there
but but even still he knows what's going
on he sees like what's happening even if
he's not taking part in it he's still
guilty by not saying anything about it
you know not doing anything about it and
continuing to let it happen like oh yeah
that's just Jeffrey being Jeffrey yeah
you know ah it's just that it's just the
usual rape of minors nothing new you
know I'm so curious to who else is there
there has to be so many politicians in
session yeah looking money and power
corrupts all even Jeffrey Epstein's
lawyer was [ __ ] there all that and
you know he pleads his innocence saying
I had no you know part of it I was just
there in a professional capacity yeah
but come on man really like the girl
said she's seen the dude with you know
oh come on max Maxwell no no no that
like so that one of the main victims
okay yeah like one of the girls that
Jeffrey was kind of pimping out and that
you know he used to
I forgot what her name was but yeah she
was like one of the the primary focus of
the documentary when they when they said
her name like jillaine max with but they
just only referred to as Maxwell I
thought they were talking about the arm
be single so I was like the whole time
only what the [ __ ] Maxwell dude I was
so confused reading the article at first
and when people asked me to read about
it because my buddy Nick he told me
about the Epstein stuff and I started
looking into it huh it's all [ __ ] up
situations yeah I was like what the [ __ ]
did Maxwell do right these are be songs
about I mean like it's [ __ ] crazy bro
they pretty much
had a ring like in a child abuse child
rape ring that's what is it that's so
[ __ ] weird I mean the thing is it's
like dude even Jeffrey Epstein bro like
you look at kind of his rise to
prominence and well mm-hmm he lied his
way through it yeah you know he like he
lied on his resume to get a job right
you know he literally [ __ ] [ __ ]
his way through his whole life yeah and
a very successful yeah and then he
connected himself a powerful people made
money for powerful people first of all
extorted them after that's [ __ ] nuts
dude
what a [ __ ] psychopath and a genius
and yeah yeah so bit him in the ass
though yeah he's uh the fact that he
he's gotten or he did get away with it
for as long as he did though what does
that say man you know that again it just
reinforced his idea you got money you
got power you know you got connections
like you never know what the [ __ ]
somebody goes through man like I I just
uh or like what really who they are
behind closed doors and that's why I'm
saying like some of these people out
there who are so pious and righteous I'm
like you guys are some of the most
[ __ ] up human beings for sure you're
hiding something dude did nobody is not
flawed you know what I mean everybody
has their problems everybody has their
flaws it's just whether or not yeah you
can be honest about it you know that's
why that's why I like I always say and I
try as much as possible not to judge
anybody ever because it's not my place
to do especially like though I mean
about judging Will Smith Will Smith is
like one of my heroes like who would say
he's not exactly [ __ ] when we were
talking about this earlier to where the
the Shane Dawson dude oh yeah that
youtuber yeah apparently this fool has
done so many public apology before this
behavior and I did this like one little
tweet was like I was like everybody
needs to be forgiven for their past life
like like when they apologize and like
people can change that move when you're
on your four thousand seven and 18 I
apologize like I think that's yeah I
don't [ __ ] did I tell you yeah and
that's that [ __ ] right and I
feel like too with this with with this
cat Shane I feel like he got away with
the law
the stuff that he said because he's a
very flamboyant gay dude yeah he's like
that she's [ __ ] you know Shane this
is not a comment on gay guys but I feel
like you know a lot of the gay home he
said I have they say [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
yeah but for some reason when they do
yeah comes off a little funnier maybe
because of the flamboyance because of
how extra they are there's a lot more
hilarious yeah yeah and I think a lot of
the people around him probably let him
skate by with these type of commas
because always just shame being Shane
yeah but when you make a joke about like
molesting an 11 year old girl where's
the comedy in that like where's where's
hook there's no comedy and you know he
kind of wrote his apology saying that he
would just stay say stuff for shock
value right
maybe this [ __ ] has Asperger's I
don't know yeah maybe he has some type
of maybe he's on the spectrum or
something yeah I guess some sort of
condition right but it's so odd when
people look at these type of behaviors
and they go oh my god he's so funny like
he's so genius it's like are you [ __ ]
kidding me you know yeah that's a thing
man is I mean we just talked about this
about it being too PC and comedy and
there being a lie like I something like
molesting a [ __ ] minor there might be
a line there bro come on man what's the
joke yeah what is the joke in that like
I could I could see you saying that for
shock value but don't be surprised if
majority that people are taking offense
to that or or just being like yo that's
that's [ __ ] out of line man and I
guess like it's also congruent to who he
is recently too because he's also done a
lot of more sus things I don't say too
recent but I think I think that clip was
when she was 11 I don't know how old
Willow Smith is now she's like 18 or
some [ __ ] yeah I think she's like 18
years older so that's like seven years
in her past but he's also had a lot of
[ __ ] up since that so I think it's more
like how many times can you apologize or
is it just exactly our and do we really
want to support somebody like exactly
like I said I'm not too hot into like
cancel culture but muhfucka what the
hell man what are you making molestation
makalah station jokes about a [ __ ] 11
year old what are the Smiths what are
the [ __ ] Smith
that's [ __ ] entertainment royalty
[ __ ] actually exactly and the
thing is is that like you said is that
if there's a consistent pattern of
behavior and like you're apologizing for
the same type of [ __ ] over and over
again chances are that's what you are
know like and you're not really sorry
for you're sorry that you got backlash
that's what you're sorry about but yeah
it's it's pretty [ __ ] wild man that
somebody like that if somehow someway
has survived it you know and yes I stays
relevant it's I gotta read [ __ ] I
remember Jaden and also Jaden and Jada
mhm
tweeted that yeah yeah they did yeah so
Jane said Shane Dawson I'm disgusted by
you you sexualizing an eleven-year-old
girl this is all caps by the way yes
screaming yeah who happens to be my
sister is the furthest furthest thing
from funny and not okay in the slightest
bit unpopular opinion I think Shane did
this and multiple other things like such
as a joke
also these actions were in the past
meaning he took criticism then and
worked on setting a better example
because no one should be painted as a
pedo when it was a joke that's what
somebody wrote one of his fans uh-huh
yeah but that's like he did it like six
or seven there's a pattern of behavior
it's not a one-off thing it was like oh
I was genuinely just trying to be funny
but I guess I crossed the line there and
I see that and I was like twelve times
like a man might just be you bro might
be a little bit like even me trying to
joke about that makes me feel weird and
I'm a crass human being and I say some
weird fucked-up [ __ ] so you know that's
even also taken taking into
consideration that in some parts of the
world for example some parts of like
South America it's okay to marry like a
thirteen-year-old
a child no you know that that's their
culture that's how it is like it
wouldn't be considered rape there right
but even with that consideration that in
some parts of the world that's deemed
normal it's feels we
is [ __ ] ya talking about that or joking
about that because of the society we
live in
yeah because the culture you know we
have so yeah for me it's just like yeah
look man joking is is is a great for the
soul to make people laugh to laugh
yourself all of that but molesting a
child I don't know what to tell you man
like this is this is one of those hard
things that's gonna be very difficult
for you to come back from the the Smiths
are against you dude the Smiths are a
[ __ ] powerhouse man like I was saying
earlier do you think about how many
millions of people he offended because
of that you know like just just wills
fanbase man like and and everybody loves
will you know know who's a huge you know
who Willow Smith what was or paper
probably still is a huge fan of who
[ __ ] Clara oh really yeah like like
she used to comment on Clara [ __ ] all
the time
well and I didn't know who Willow Smith
was Yeah right yeah and I didn't I
didn't know at the time that when little
Smith when she dropped that one singing
cause of dannis little girls crazy yeah
yeah and not crazy in a bad way but ya
know she's like oh yeah and then yeah
because that generation is a YouTube
generation yeah but she looked up to
Clara truant sure that makes asking
crazy and I actually have a Willow Smith
story oh really yeah I was asked
Starbucks with Z and then we were in
line uh you know just waiting to order
and I felt somebody's staring at me you
know like that feeling you get when
somebody's staring at you right and then
I'm like who's staring at me like what
direction is it coming from right
because I could feel eyes on me but I
don't know who it is so I started kind
of like looking around and then I turned
in direction it was Willow Smith and she
was just staring at me in line and I
turn around and looked at her and and I
locked eyes with her and then I was like
why does she look so familiar and then
like that was at a point where she did
the whip my hair oh yeah so it's like
she was still relevant in that sense
like as a actually she's still relevant
now I'm not saying that but she's like
her her I guess stardom really kind of
was peaking at that point right and the
song I'm looking
and her and it felt like a long time but
I'm sure we were just like staring at
each other for maybe about like five
seconds and I was trying to process in
my head why does this girl look so
familiar like who is she and why oh [ __ ]
that's Willow Smith and then uh next
thing I thought was she was just there
with a friend I'm like where the [ __ ] is
her security like she's a minor
yeah where's her bodyguard or security
guard like don't tell me you know the
Will and Jada is just letting her out
and I think at that point she might have
been like 13 what the [ __ ] 13 14 she's
doing it with a friend help yeah yeah
well more so now I'm not saying that 13
14 year olds can't hang out but because
she's a celebrity yeah that's you know
weird yeah and then so uh after I looked
at her and I realized who she was next
thing I was thinking like is where's her
body go so I started looking around the
room and then I saw one dude kind of
sitting incognito has a hat on and he
was just staring at you I don't know
I really don't know I would like to ask
her hey do you remember that asian guy
yeah I don't know I was like do I do I
look funny right now do I got something
on me and I told yo and s Will Smith
right there and he's like oh [ __ ] I was
like yeah she was just staring at me
I don't know why like staring at me and
like it like dogging me or anything you
know yeah I I just don't know like huge
first time I ever saw an Asian person
you guys yeah and then yes like I got we
got our drinks and then like she got her
drinks and then like yet they left with
the security guard but man Will Smith
kids though they're talented man they
are like I like he just for them to to
be able to carve out their own space and
entertainment in their own unique way
such a challenge it's hard because they
have to live in the shadow of the bottom
right and obviously like the greatness
of his father is who he is right but I
kind of appreciate it I mean the move-up
get weird but I'm gonna get Jana
weirdest I know people like well what
defines weird David what's the Society
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] weird he's on the
leads in the left side yeah left field
okay he's definitely left field as [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] he is I'm not saying it's
a bad thing I'm just saying he's
[ __ ] different but he's carved
his his own identity and I think it's
very authentic it doesn't seem like he's
trying hard either right I think because
of kind of the the creative way that his
father has raised him and his mother has
raised him and including their daughter
yeah they just different and yeah they
do different in a very in my personal
opinion in kind of a dope way yeah you
know yeah I mean look when I think about
that situation I do think like there's a
sense of you're trying to become like a
celebrity or a public figure in some way
and obviously if you're trying to do it
through the avenue of acting that's some
big shoes to fill
right Oh after earth is one of the most
terrible films I've ever seen [ __ ]
after Earth I deserve we'd all deserve a
public apology and I want my one and a
half hours back in my life [ __ ] that
film yeah but then but then the thing is
I'm sure there was kind of a sense of
like I got it I got a carve out my own
lane you know I got to do something
different and and like I I would imagine
whether it was like a conscious decision
or just on a subconscious level that it
kind of pushed him to be a little bit
more different and and pursue kind of a
different thing because yeah Will Smith
was also a popular artist as a musician
too right but it wasn't like his bread
and butter you know that it wasn't when
he was like starting out but then he
became a [ __ ] international movie
star and that's what people really
recognized Will Smith as like yeah he'll
make a soundtrack for the movies he's
doing but nobody's thinking like I will
submit the music artists they're
thinking Will Smith the actor right so I
feel like in that sense maybe it kind of
pushed him a little bit harder into
going into that left field
area right to be a little bit weirder to
kind of stand out a little yeah yeah for
sure the cool thing is I feel he's kind
of built his own success not off of his
father's name but off of his own
branding his own style and whatever he
does
yeah which like I said it's so [ __ ]
hard to do like for example look at
Jordans kid mm-hmm you know people had
high hopes for him because he's the son
of Jordan and you know even before he
was even given a chance or to really
show what he's about people are like oh
you better be it just as good as your
[ __ ] see yeah right you know we're just
a lot to live up by yeah man and I think
like they've kind of in their own right
just done their own thing and I was like
I could really [ __ ] with them yeah and
the most important thing is they seemed
happy do we yeah that's I think that's
the most important thing because I feel
like kids who have those type of parents
who are celebrities and like that cast a
big shadow I mean it's easy for them to
fall into depression because of like not
only what other people want from you but
because of expectations placed on you
get a [ __ ] film like after earth [ __ ]
that film watch this I can't even sure
it's on it it's like it's really short
uh-huh but it's I think I saw it about
six times and I was in like six parts
for me to just to finish it because how
bad it was I'm so upset and it's [ __ ]
Will Smith yeah
it's boy I mean I love all the Will
Smith [ __ ] yeah I mean look man it's
great as well as he's done some pretty
questionable projects in the in the like
past few years I'm trying to figure out
what other movie that he did that I
didn't like well there was that one on
Netflix where he's a cop
you know I forgot what that one was that
one got pretty bad reviews that was
weird I didn't know that was a film I
thought it was good I thought it like a
TV series and that's the kind of vibe
that I got from Myles like as a
standalone episode this is pretty good
as a film it kind of just started out of
nowhere didn't go anywhere didn't end
anywhere either so I didn't understand
what the what the point of it was but I
think it was terrible I think it
would've been a great episode in a
series ya know but like well well like
he can do no wrong even if he does wrong
it's just like easily forgettable
because watch this will be on Epstein's
Island oh I'm I'm cutting everything out
dude I'm deleting this [ __ ] podcast
life have any hope no was there yeah I
would lose faith in mankind if he's
getting jiggy with it on that island and
I would be so sick I'll be so [ __ ]
upset but yeah I mean he's for every The
Fresh Prince of bel-air man like he's
he's always doing something
I remember when he [ __ ] join social
media man like that oh my god I even
killed YouTube you do YouTube ad than
YouTube yeah exactly
it was like dude Will Smith is on
[ __ ] Instagram Will Smith is on
social hour like on YouTube like this is
gonna be interesting to see and then
like he said he took it to a level that
I didn't think he was gonna do because I
was curious how he's gonna utilize the
platform is it just gonna be like a plug
for the projects he's working but not he
treated that thing like its own project
you know without money to do it too so
his editors are [ __ ] I think I'm
Michael Bay edit one for ya I mean he
has the money to hire a crew to follow
100% yeah I think that if there's a few
people on this earth that I want it like
sit down and have a really long
conversation with Will Smith is
definitely one of them man for sure Will
Smith would you like to come on the
genius probably you don't know you call
my son weird you're forever blacklisted
in my book I'm always saying your son's
weird because he introduced your wife to
[ __ ] little [ __ ] that's what he did
you [ __ ] set it up speaking of that
dude how I imagine how [ __ ] weird it
must be that to know that your [ __ ]
mom is having sexual relations with your
friend you know as I I'm sorry man I
think I'm gonna fight that friend you
know I wonder how Jaden feels about that
I don't know that's like dog I brought
you over for some milk and cookies yeah
[Laughter]
you took a putting your hand in the
cookie jar to a different place new pops
we can't be friends I'm your pops you
call me Papa coming daddy
look man I you know I I don't know how
I'd be able to process and deal with
that like like I said I think I would
just have to fight it dude it's like
look man maybe I'm gonna process it
different later but for right now we
just got a fight I need to get that [ __ ]
out I wonder who would win in a fight
August I'll senior Jaden Smith I don't I
don't even know what the dude looks like
so he's like a he's a good looking dude
he's like light-skinned
he's a light-skinned endued he kind of
like Chris Brown I'm almost sort of I
might just be clumping them all together
yeah but you know Jana Smith is a
good-looking dude - yeah but it's just
beat the Battle of the light skins and
see what happens maybe I don't know man
that's yeah but that's that shit's a s
wild man like even if even if they were
separated the fact that she was having a
relationship with somebody who's like
what 30 no 20-some years we're when you
start to when when you kind of grow up
you have this idea of what a perfect
relationship is and what these couples
are and then you find out and this is
where anybody out there you'll find out
that like 70% of these couples that you
know they either are gonna break up or
they have some [ __ ] up [ __ ] about them
like it's very very rare that I see a
couple that's seemingly perfect in and
out ya know it doesn't exist perkily
perfect doesn't exist you know what I
mean like every couple is most likely
going through similar issues and
problems throughout the relationship
that other couples go through yeah it's
it's all [ __ ] up yeah that's the crazy
thing too and it makes sometimes it
makes me questions like why do I even
want to be in a long-term relationship
like what [ __ ] my thinking the thing
is is how you handle it how you deal
with it as a couple right now is I mean
that's the most important thing and and
like you know I think one thing that I
always try to do is I try to speak to
people who are more advanced and a more
advanced age than I am
and let's say in life or just experience
right and and marriage and couples is
like one of those topics right where I
seek more information about it and I
think when you talk to a lot of these
people who have been married for let's
say five 10 15 20 years right and you
talk to them about like what works for
them I mean they're not ever gonna say
oh yeah we don't have any problems
anymore it's just that there are key
ingredients to making the relationships
stay successful and stay working and one
of the biggest thing is communication
right any any couple that tells you that
they don't have any problems the ones
that have blatantly said that shouldn't
in front of my face all of us were like
calling [ __ ] and lo and behold
they're the
ones with the biggest [ __ ] problems
right and it's very easy for somebody to
just go up on social media and say like
this is my perfect life 101 block and I
look at it I'm like you two I haven't
had sex in years you [ __ ] broke in
Hulme and I find that so often too and
it's because they like to have that
megaphone I don't know why they do that
maybe it's just to hide their
insecurities but they blast out that the
relationship is perfect and it I see a
hundred percent of the time that that
[ __ ] is never true of course you're
hiding something that yours and you have
to go out of your way to do that when
your relationship is [ __ ] up it's such
a weird thing to me and and and such a
dangerous thing for these kids to like
consume because they start to get this
idea that there is a perfect
relationship there is a perfect you know
person everybody's flawed everybody's
imperfect everybody you know has some
sort of problems that they got to deal
with but then it's like when you bring
in another person into that picture and
you guys decide to become a team it's
like okay how do you tackle those
problems as a team now sometimes those
problems are gonna exist more on the
individual side sometimes it's gonna
exist together but again it's like how
do you support one another how do you
communicate how do you stay honest with
each other and then productively get
past it and and it's like easier said
than done obviously because sometimes
people close up sometimes people aren't
honest about what they're feeling or
honest about the problems that exist
sometimes they don't communicate it so
like there's so many obstacles that you
got to get past sometimes in order for
you to get to where you want to get you
but do you think that you could stay
with somebody if they had cheated on you
it'd be really hard because for me I
think Trust is one another one in those
big pillars except to make a strong
relationship communication honesty you
know trust whatever right but not
whatever there's [ __ ] no but if
somebody cheated on me it's a violation
of trust you know and so like I don't
know if somebody's [ __ ] snail trail
dick is all over your face are you
[ __ ] kidding me disgusting so just
because like for me
I'm like I'm a principal guy I don't
know who knows yeah I and so like for me
my principles really would not allow me
to like cheat on somebody I like I I
could say with a hundred percent
certainty you know that I wouldn't do
that to a person I'm with but then if
let's say like my partner did it to me I
mean my first instinct would be to say
no I don't think I would be able to
overlook that this is by the way they
cheat on you you don't have kids you
don't have property yeah yeah yeah no
that's a factor yeah because the likely
that the fact that it happened there's
always a possibility for it to happen
again yeah you know and so look I'm not
saying that somebody can't learn from
that and then you know get improved from
it but the fact that he didn't even
happened in the first place that your
judgment and your principles were kind
of grayed out for you yeah in order for
you to let that whatever your reasoning
it oh but it's because you never paid
attention to me it's because you don't
show me affection like if you can really
come to that conclusion and justify it
even and be defensive about it yes it's
not something that yeah like we're just
courses in relationship gonna go from
here right I don't know it's hard for me
like I thought about to but I've
actually known a couple actually had
quite a few people who have been cheated
on before and they they kind of went
through it and they came out stronger at
the other end of it a more power to them
yeah you know and I think it's it's
different right it's it's I think was
sometimes when people think about
somebody cheating on their spouses both
they think that it's just something that
happens at a whim where I think they saw
some ass or they saw some the tip of
somebody's dick and they're just like oh
this is what happens but there's a lot
of underlying issues that happen here
and lead to this point I'm sure and so
just one out of these couples they kind
of had a conversation they were all very
open about it with me as a friend from
Sacramento and they were kind of talking
about what they went through and what
was going on and a lot of it had to do
with no communication mm-hmm where they
wouldn't tell each other how they felt
about certain things a big problem and
so there was something that was missing
in their relationship that this other
stranger was fulfilling that the other
person wasn't absolutely and it wasn't
that that other person could make that
them whole it was just that one little
piece that they needed from their other
partner that was very important that
they got from somebody else and the sad
part about that is they wanted to have
their cake and eat it too and but
because they still love the other person
Adel they were in essentially what they
were doing with the person that they
were cheating with they were just using
them to fulfill that small part but they
still loved the other person and when
that [ __ ] came to a head and she decided
to actually tell him that she was
cheating because she couldn't live with
the guilt all hell broke loose you know
obviously right and it was it was a
terrible thing but what they found out
in and when they cheated or why she
cheated was actually because of
something that he wasn't doing for her
and so what I mean by that is that I'm
not excusing her [ __ ] behavior but
there is a there was some fault on his
head his end because she said that but
he admitted this too
that she would try to address certain
issues in their relationship and he
would just always throw it back at her
as if she's being crazy and she's just
being hyper emotional yeah and because
he was very dismissive of how she felt
she found somebody that would listen to
her and she kind of fell quote-unquote
in love with somebody else that was
fulfilling something that she very much
needed and it was something that she
brought to him but because he didn't
want to communicate that with her and
then he was surprising it was I can't
believe you cheated on me why well I'm
not justifying what she did but she did
try to talk to you she did try to have
these conversations and then you're
sitting over here because you thought
everything was fine in your world even
though she was crying for help and then
you're kind of over here in your corner
trying to be righteous about it saying
oh I don't know how this happened
everybody else did yeah I mean looks
like I mean sounds like you know there
was definitely kind of a void in in like
honesty and communication no but
definitely sounds like there was a void
there but at the same time it's like on
the girls side right if she recognizes
that that's the problem and and also
recognizes that it's not something that
they're making progress on it's not
something especially if it's important
to her right I mean as a partner if
somebody's telling you that that's
important to them and that they need
that or they want that it's something
you should listen to and at least
entertain at the very least right but if
you're just being dismissive and just
ignoring it that's a terrible position
to put them out but so like for on the
girls side I can understand why it might
have made her feel just like deflated
and in like unimportant but the solution
isn't to go out and find another dude
then like if you can't of course I mean
yeah that mean that definitely wasn't a
solution yeah what I'm the thing that I
understand is that or I want people
understand is in their case like he was
shocked then as if it happened out of
knowing okay and a lot of my friends too
we kind of saw it right and they were
one of those people too that they would
always say they never fought you know
that everything was great and fine but
it wasn't really so much she was saying
he would always say it all the time
which which I'll be honest it [ __ ]
annoyed me like cuz nobody I'm over here
fighting with my girlfriend every
[ __ ] time
you know he's over here like dude like
let me just tell you man these fights
aren't worth it you know me and blah
blah blah Blee I don't even remember the
last time he fought [ __ ] you [ __ ] she
was sucking somebody else's dick you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know it was almost
like he was trying to make me feel bad
about the problems that I was having
with the girls with my girlfriend at the
time but it was like you're so [ __ ]
dumb you don't even know what's going on
right in front of your eyes man yeah
well I'm feel so bad for saying this but
a whole mother [ __ ] I'm so happy oh I'm
so fun I can't I stay listen everything
I'm saying on this podcast I've already
clown on him about I go huzzah
you like that [ __ ] yeah
nobody's like yeah man I [ __ ] up I was
like yeah dude yeah you you were kind of
like laying it hard on me sometimes
talking about like oh man
you're saying that the [ __ ] that I was
going through with some immature [ __ ]
when really it was just me trying to
figure out we were we were just open
about how we felt then we were arguing
because we couldn't understand each
other yeah I was like you wouldn't even
argue you would just shut her ass down
and make her feel like she was dumb yeah
I'm Hinch I Love You Man
the thing is though is like yeah well I
see what you're saying of like why is
this a surprise to you you know when
when this was clearly going on at the
same time it's like you know if you guys
aren't first of all able to do it in a
healthy manner figure out your problems
in a healthy productive manner then you
have to come to terms with the the
possibility that you guys just aren't
compatible with each other for long term
anyway I think in this case though it
was more like it's not that they weren't
compatible and that no matter what the
stuff that he was doing and mind you I'm
I was his friend first yeah yeah I mean
I met him through a couple of homies
back in the day but I was his friends
first before I met her so if anything
else my loyalty lies with him yeah but
he this is a problem that he would have
no matter what whether it's with this
girl or somebody else it's you know kind
of like talking to a woman as if she's
crazy because she feels something that
he doesn't understand right it's gonna
be problematic either way well how she
dealt with it was [ __ ] terrible but
it was kind of interesting because this
was the first time I it kind of cast a
doubt in my head of oh would I leave
somebody if they cheated on me if we
been through so much and there's a bit
of Fault on my side too like would I
leave them or could we become stronger
from this mhm and it actually made me
change my mind a little bit about cuz I
was so it's such a hard stance on it it
was I wouldn't leave this person to 100%
now I'm wondering now I'm like 70% eight
ninety eight ninety ninety percent I'd
leave now that 10 percent doubt is there
like oh maybe I'd be strong enough to
fight it out but if the thought of me
laying down and I'm like somebody's dick
was in that mouth you know like son of a
[ __ ]
people are like well they had sex before
you that's different yeah when you get
with somebody else you're a born-again
virgin all right you were baptized in
somebody else's Newcomb is different
yeah like I said it would just be really
hard to kind of get past the whole
violation of trust that you have yeah
it's like you know every time they go
out to get some milk I'm like [ __ ] what
kind of milk you going out for it
exactly like what type of Colgate you
use it like weird yeah why usually so
[ __ ] peacefully right now the best
part that would bother me my every day
after so I'll [ __ ] like yeah cuz then
once that seed is planted in your mind
you know it might it might not be an
easy thing to like rid your thoughts of
so you know have you ever been cheated
on before no no I haven't so I don't
have any personal experience so I can
only speak hypothetically about it
but I talk about it more so from a
standpoint of like what I find important
you know I mean I don't know if it was
cheating per se but you but you meant
that girl the the one the can't say in
her name but the one that I was and that
wasn't a serious relationship prior to
Mariel mm-hmm
so that girl she she dated she was
trying to get with somebody else while
we were together
oh and I thought that I could move past
it right uh-huh and it wasn't even that
she was doing it to [ __ ] in a very
vengeful way that's yeah you know that's
that's [ __ ] terrible so just to kind
of give tell people this story this was
like the first time that man it's
probably second time [ __ ] be cheating
on she there was a friend that I had
right
she and I were very close but prior to
me getting with her she knows that I
have a lot of close female friends right
but the reason why they're friends is
because we understand why we're friends
yeah no [ __ ] attraction but this girl
that I was friends with we had a brief
moment were very very flirtatious the
be I say we were kind of dating um I was
very upfront about it and I told her
because I wanted to be very
straightforward yeah and I'm not trying
to tell you that I'm a great guy but I
want people to know the type of
relationships that I have with people
because I'm trying to think of like how
I would feel in that situation so I told
her that Abe this girl and I we never we
never hooked up or anything like that
but we should be very flirtatious like I
used to chase after this girl but I
don't find her attractive at all
thousand percent like I'm talking about
I'd [ __ ] chop off my left foot before
I had to put my mouth on it yeah right
yeah but you know we're friends I was
like if you don't want me to be around
her because it makes you feel
uncomfortable let me know and she would
understand too because of our past and
it makes it a little awkward yeah and
she goes she goes no no no she met her
too she knows of her they've actually
mingled throughout each other's circles
so she goes yeah no that's perfectly
fine I love her she's super cool I could
trust I trust you fine
she said that without believing in yeah
I believed her yeah she said it so
convincingly I hadn't while the the time
that she and I were together I hung out
with her once for a shoot uh-huh um I'll
shoot that bug you look too much but she
was on she was on a couple of my videos
yeah back in the day a thousand of my
videos you'll never know what and she I
hung out with her once before and and
with her right I hung out with her the
second time while she with my girlfriend
her and my brother there and so it was
for people Yeah right
and she and I have a very joking funny
relationship mind you I don't find her
attractive I'm very [ __ ] clear about
that [ __ ] yeah later on I found out that
she kind of calls me up and you know
people will feel guilty especially if
you don't do anything wrong to them yeah
there's nothing that you've done yeah to
elicit that type of response right you
know she's a good I think she still is a
really good girl but I think that guilt
was eating her up so that night that we
were hanging out I kind of got these
weird signs and I never pieced it
together but she was a lot more
touchy-feely in front of everybody right
like she was like putting her hand in my
back pocket I was very possessive right
it's kind of like what a guy does to a
girl when he puts his hand
girl's lower back out there together to
let other guys know hey we together you
know she was doing the female version of
that right but I remember we had a
grocery store and she's like doing in a
really agretti was I don't mind her
grabbing my ass but it was more like it
didn't feel comfortable yeah it didn't
feel natural yeah it's like you're a lot
more touchy-feely she goes wide like she
goes like were you never like that yeah
I should like were to get you do a [ __ ]
like that which is not like her you know
and I was like the hell I was kind of
weirded out by it but I don't mind but
later that night I was like hey we're
gonna go get dessert let's all decide to
go to a dessert place after we had
dinner and then she was kind of acting a
little weird and she goes well um I'm
just gonna go home right like my mom
what kind of wants to see me we haven't
hung out because she came all the way
from North Cali yeah I mean she was
visiting me because she was in pharmacy
school at the time car and I'll say okay
so like whatever whatnot give her a kiss
goodbye and she leaves and it's me my
brother and the other girl we're hanging
out three people she and I are not alone
together I she and I were never alone
together and made sure that [ __ ] because
even if she told me it was okay I watch
out for my deafness right I don't want
anybody to give me a reason for anything
right yeah I want people knowing nothing
going on for sure yeah and I thought
that was respectful I never hung out
with that girl alone and that was twice
and we were together for about eight
months
I saw her twice once for a work reasons
and the second time was with her because
she said they were friends and so she
actually left that night later on to go
hang out with another guy and I don't
know what the [ __ ] they did she said
like they didn't you know hook up or
anything but they did some [ __ ] or
whatever right and I remember this
moment too because I was in the
apartment and Jason Chen and Joseph
Vincent were shooting a [ __ ] video in
my apartment yeah and she told she was
telling me this over the phone and bro I
was screaming at the top of my [ __ ]
lungs and they're trying to do a funny
music video yeah but I'm ruining the
mood
yeah I'm like what the [ __ ] yeah are you
[ __ ] kidding me and then they could
hear me like break [ __ ] in my room cuz I
was so [ __ ] mad and the reason why I
was so mad wasn't even the cheating part
right I didn't do anything
yeah it was all in her own head right
right it's just her insecurity it was
her insecurity I was like what and I
so I was like what could I have done to
make this better mm-hmm what could I
have done right and the thing that I
want to reflect back on and the the
responsibility that I had to take was
that in all honesty is probably because
I don't think I really he loved her you
know as she probably felt that a little
bit they should probably love me more
than I loved her I didn't like that girl
but she felt something was missing and
that's the responsibility that I had to
take yeah but obviously what she did was
[ __ ] outlandish yeah then I was so
[ __ ] mad and I and it was it was she
did that she was she met it with this
dude that was like in a part of her
church and they both lived in Southern
California so during the time they were
on break and yeah met up and I was like
a church boy mm-hmm [ __ ] are you uh is
this a Korean drama you had to do the
classic church cheating that's like the
[ __ ] pastor that hooks up with the
piano lady and they were in the praise
team together uh-huh
and I remember I was so [ __ ] mad and
this is during the time this is like
recently this is I haven't been in LA
that long yeah so during this time I was
still connected to some very bad people
you know and specifically out in the
[ __ ] Stockton Modesto area well
that's [ __ ] hood is [ __ ] yeah I
actually found out where he lived
I was that [ __ ] mad yeah I remember I
hung up that phone that day I was like
you know he's [ __ ] dead right yeah I
hung up that phone I hit up a couple of
homies and I found out where he live
because the school that she attended the
university they she attend it's very
[ __ ] small I found out where he lived
or his parents were and everything
literally was on the phone I was like is
this his name first and last name this
is his address and she got dead quiet
uh-huh I was like he's gonna get [ __ ]
up today Yeah right and then she was
like he's a good guy and then I and then
I had this moment to where I remember I
was like get the [ __ ] are you doing yeah
and I remember I felt like a loser
because I let her and that guy control
my emotions and then I was like you know
what he's good I was like all I know is
that I'm by g'way I'm not tell you I'm
super mature because a week later I flew
in the town and we were reconciling this
and then we thought we were gonna get
over it I thought I was but I literally
told her I was like when I come into
town you guys are in church together
I was like that whole week that I'm in
town he needs to not be in the city you
need not be in the city yeah and then
she goes okay and they say no no he
actually left
so cuz I was still mad yeah and I was
still [ __ ] the matured way I wanted to
[ __ ] break that fools [ __ ] lace
yeah specifically because he did in the
name of the Lord praise Dean you [ __ ]
Jezebel but I thought that I could get
over that right but that should always
stuck with me yes that's what I'm saying
and the thing is it's like you know it's
not necessarily like a bad quality in
you as a human being if you can't get
past that or you find that important
enough in a relationship where it's a
deal breaker
you know everybody will have different
stances and different extremities of how
they consider certain parts of
relationship how important they deem a
certain part of a relationship and it's
like to me you know trust and honesty is
really important and if somebody
violates like there shouldn't ever be a
moment where you should question like
whether or not you could trust your
partner whether or not you can be open
about your about your honesty about your
honest feelings to your partner and I
feel like when something like that
happens it's a violation at the very
least of trust and a violation of
honesty as well because it was it
obviously came to light at some point
yeah I mean and you like I'll still
defend her she's a very sweet girl like
she she's an awesome girl like I think
she's really amazing I don't think that
she has like the evil bone in her body
but the way that she kind of expressed
her discontent in our relationship was a
terrible way to do and Security's a
[ __ ] bro yeah yeah like you couldn't be
jealous of somebody else yeah she
actually she's my friend in terms of
like out of all the people in the world
you know I'm like you know I was around
some bad [ __ ] like why the [ __ ] out
of all the people I'm like God what the
[ __ ] but that's the thing man it's like
insecurity will drive people to do crazy
[ __ ] bro I've been on the receiving end
of that where I had you know a jealous
girlfriend and like dealing with that
was not easy because I'm not like that
you know because my thing is
it's like dude if I trust you I trust
you you know in my mind too though for
me it was like [ __ ] I'm surprised she
liked me you think it's gonna take me
away you think about what you think I'm
rod dog owner of my brother's watching
like what are you thinking is happening
right now you know what I'm saying it's
like you you were there John John is
holding the camera yeah what is going on
in your [ __ ] mind you know that's
what I'm saying it could those thoughts
can go to crazy places when they're
insecure yeah I mean look man I've been
accused of [ __ ] because of a girl's
insecurity of where it's like absolutely
[ __ ] ridiculous to me but in their
mind it's a realistic scenario it's a
realistic possibility I'm just like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about you know
but that's what I'm saying it's like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] are you talking to who's
like my mom
what the [ __ ] is mom it's my mom my
mother still another girl yeah and you
know I can go both ways I've seen plenty
of times where you know my girlfriend's
like not not like romantic but like
friends that are girls have had jealous
boyfriend Hale jealousy those scary yeah
just because they get physical yeah yeah
yeah I mean they can get violent they
can you know get threatening like it's
it's not a it's not a nice thing to
witness
and what one point it got one of the
situations that got so bad that this guy
was threatening to like come to her
family's home and then like kill himself
in front of the lawn or like [ __ ] I
think they say he was gonna shoot up
shoot up the family and then like
hearing that I got so [ __ ] pissed and
I'm like tell me where to [ __ ] this do
it is right now you know like tell me
like let me [ __ ] have a conversation
with this dude because like what he's
saying is is completely out of line but
I wasn't thinking a conversation
I was thinking about to the dog yeah but
yeah he was like he was on this tip
where he just kept upping his uh his
threats right of what he's gonna do like
if because I think I think they had
broken up or something and then like he
didn't she didn't want her seeing other
people or like you know the idea that
was such a [ __ ] loser
yeah dude and that's what made me that's
what that's a thought that I had is like
dude how [ __ ] small are you you know
it's weird when people become very
possessive of somebody else right like
is their property right now it's so
weird it's like how little do you think
of yourself that you had the only way
that you can keep somebody is if you
ball and chain them you know like you
have nothing else to offer so the only
way that you could keep somebody around
you is to threaten them like you are a
loser dude for sure I'm gonna like I'm
gonna kill myself do it somebody's
family to kill them shoot yourself first
and that's crazy yeah so like you know
I've definitely heard like on the other
end and it's like yeah that's that's a
problem that both male and female people
can have it's and it's like it can get
really ugly man but for me I've I've
never been the jealous type like I said
for me because Trust is so important
because honesty is so important lucky
you man I was my first girlfriend I was
a jealous type oh really oh super
jealous man oh
at one time we were walking by and then
a tree brushed up on her arm
[Laughter]
I was super just but once again that was
because I didn't find value myself
though like I was like how could I have
gotten this girl which bride looking
back on it you pretty average but in my
mind you know I'm like this is the girl
of my dreams and anybody else who would
come in between that they're trying to
take something is almost like I felt
like I tricked her this this bar and I
can't have somebody yells realized that
the jig is up right so I thought this um
they walked into the scene they could
offer something more because I wasn't
offering her anything yeah and somehow I
just tricked her into following him help
hello my vision of myself wise was is
the girl that also subsequently broke
your heart
yep she was that she was that one she
was the one
no but yeah that's that's the thing man
is that a lot of these things come from
obviously self issues you know it's that
you gotta sort out within yourself and
that's something that I feel like is
really important going into relationship
two or two to have a healthy
relationship is you gotta make sure
you're right first to you know because
if you're not right how do you expect to
care for somebody else take care of
somebody else always [ __ ] imposter
exactly exactly so there's gonna be
constantly like issues that come up
within that but you know sometimes like
the whole mental health topic can be a
sensitive topic and some people I don't
got any problems oh I don't need to see
a specialist or a therapist what the
[ __ ] you talking about I'm good you know
but no it's it's like you just have to
look at kind of your history and in like
how you are in certain situations and
circumstances and be honest with
yourself about that so when I say
honesty - it's like not just to your
partner but with yourself - that's the
hardest part man so say I [ __ ] didn't
know I was fat especially was the
roughest conversation I've ever had with
myself she was tough say Dave are you
fat quarantine I gained like 10 pounds
and like good being I'm a little more
self-aware now and I was like man like
these shorts are cutting into my
simulation my legs started going numb
well the difference is you're aware of
it this time though I know and before I
would just blame the clothes
yeah and man these [ __ ] European cuts
they extra tight dude they've been
[ __ ] up on these sizes why they make
it I remember
in line but I was wearing like an Excel
shirt I literally said like everybody's
just doing this slim cut European [ __ ]
and it was a regular XL shirt I
convinced myself is because fashion has
changed yeah and I couldn't fit yeah and
I just found an XL that did fit me and
it was a gilded shirt oh man you know
sometimes the mental gymnastics you have
to do to justify something you know what
I mean help me live [ __ ] but yeah man
being honest with yourself is is so
crucial it's it's such it's like such a
important factor to have like successful
relationships with other people oh yeah
man yeah girls I mean it doesn't apply
to just girls and guys like in terms of
your significant other but just in any
human relationship you know yeah man I
suggest people to it's like I know
you're never gonna find a complete human
being when you meet them sometimes like
you become a complete human being
because of the journey that you take
when a person that your way but I say
like anybody who wants a long-term
relationship like you want to grow with
somebody make sure that person always
has value in themselves first I mean
people will go in and out of it will
[ __ ] up there'll be times we'll go
through our own depression and well
we'll we'll question who we are but if
that person doesn't value themselves as
an individual they're not gonna value
your your time or who you are either
it's hard to it's hard it's not it's not
because they have they don't have any
they don't have the ability yeah exactly
it's not because they want to make you
feel like [ __ ] or treat you like that
it's just like you said it like there's
something not right within themselves
yeah and and that needs to be addressed
first in order to you know like like the
good parts of that to manifest itself
into the relationship it's something as
like simple as how you know how can you
expect somebody to love you when they
don't even know what love is like mmm
that has to start right you right that's
that's as cliche as it gets but that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] facts everybody that I
know that genuinely loves other people
they love themselves first and even
these people who are a little too
gratuitous with their time and they
sometimes like sink into too much of the
the giving part yeah they still love
themselves they still like when they're
by themselves or when they have time to
themselves
that they don't get lost in being
obsessive with defining their happiness
through somebody else that they're
pretty solid so um I've made that
mistake mm-hmm I only made it once
though I never made it twice again I
will never ever do that ever again even
if if Muriel happens to leave me number
one guys you buy the CD the podcast for
another two to three months I don't if
you if you guys can't tell I don't think
breakups very well you know Brian
midnight we coming back crying to my ear
holes again you know one of the mixtapes
that I got though I forgot to mention I
made my own but my best friend made me
mixtape to he was like a baby [ __ ] for
you and I remember I told him I got
dumped and I did it in the parking lot
of a Wendy's oh well I I don't remember
what that burger tasted like crying so
much I couldn't taste anything but
that's the first time you saw me cry and
that [ __ ] was mad awkward oh [ __ ]
I cried in an empty parking lot of a
[ __ ] Wendy's that's next to this
Costco in Sacramento while you're eating
a version while I'm eating a burger
crying dude pretty [ __ ] low dude
crying into a double bacon to a
Baconator oh god you hated yourself that
much did y'all know that [ __ ] that
that video of that little kid crying my
little cute little black kid crying he's
eating a burger as he's crying yeah that
was me dude when I saw that [ __ ]
everybody was laughing I wasn't laughing
I'm like that's just real sad this is
the mood I'm in right now man I can't I
can't help it I understand what it's
like the crying to a hamburger I'm sorry
man I can't relate you heartless fool
I've I don't know man I've never been
like I guess on that level
I hope somebody breaks your [ __ ]
heart dude I'll really do I wish
somebody just breaks your [ __ ] heart
hope so my I hope you fall in love and
they just [ __ ] thank you
right into a verse right dude you need
to be a human being that's a problem you
gotta fix it in yourself
0:05 did y'all want you to feel that
pain like devastated I want you to wake
up one day and just start listening to
[ __ ] I don't know Shaddai just crying
into your ear holes don't get me wrong
man like any breakup is not easy but at
the same time it's like I don't think
I've ever kind of fallen into like those
cliche scenarios you know that you see
in TV shows and movies and like you
listen to like these sad songs with your
girl who's gonna listen to this right
now she's like what the [ __ ]
say if I leave you right now you wanna
cry you're gonna cry for me it's
heartless bastard I told Mary old man I
was like if you leave me I was like I'm
not leaving you you have to leave me I
was like I've invested so much time this
and I just and I genuinely like if you
leave me I hope you know that you just
left the man devastated anyway you have
a little you ruin the [ __ ] man I
might not come out of this yeah just
just to put it out there so I'm just
gonna let you know I told her that yeah
look I can't I can't do it yeah like
I've invested a lot of time I feel like
you know things are going well if I
don't know where you're like you know
what I feel like I don't love you
anymore yeah I'm a collapse to my knees
and glamour angles
I'd be like don't leave me please i'ma
grab Ernie yeah she's gonna try to leave
and she's just gonna drag me across the
floor by the way I'm say this because
I've actually done this before
oh my god so dramatic what the first
girlfriend doing when she dumped me this
girl is
number uh I told you I I mean I I've
learned the most from my very first
relationship because I did everything
that a person shouldn't do and I never
did it again I went back on that [ __ ]
dude
Dahl ice crumbled I crumbled like a
Jenga stack in front of her I just
collapsed and I was like don't leave me
bro eighteen-year-old David was a
[ __ ] emotional oh [ __ ]
give this advice I'm telling people I'm
not saying that you're dumb I'm saying
I've already done this already been
there like don't do this it's not worth
it
how pitiful it is whatsoever I literally
collapsed the floor and I begged her to
stay Oh crying internee caps crying into
her [ __ ] kneecaps as she was crying
on top of my head layer of my best
friend and I cried it to that Baconator
oh my god that's such a sad sad thing
too [ __ ] picture cord okay
I just remember looking at him and he
just couldn't say anything he just put
his hand on my shoulder and you're just
so your friend was actually with you he
was there okay he's the one that drove
me like he drove me to the [ __ ]
wedding so we could talk cuz you know
what Papa likes let me show you and take
you to check him in that leg
oh man yeah I'm sorry man I've never you
heartless [ __ ] I hope you deal with
that [ __ ] what they meant
oh I don't know man I don't think it's
in me to like yeah dude your dad's like
that thing your dad doesn't have that
she did not my pops ain't like that dude
my pop dude my pops is like that that
old generation Korean dude you know what
I mean like showing his emotions is is
like almost he's almost incapable of
Union you know what I mean and as a
result I think a lot of
that kind of got passed on to me because
like you know our family was never the
the like verbal affirmation of love and
like you know hugging and things it was
never that you know so I think it it
kind of shaped me you know a a certain
way and um as a result it's it's hard
for me to like be expressive with my
emotions Wow but but to offset that I
can be very expressive of my thoughts
you know what I'm thinking and then I
just picture you just saying happy
birthday to your girlfriend all you do
is say it is your birthday
I mean look man I've it's something that
I've recognized that I I'm a little bit
deficient in and and I've tried to
improve on it but it's not gonna be like
a night and day difference
you know it's in a short amount of time
it's I'm trying to kind of like go
against a lifetime of this [ __ ] to to
work on it and you know what in the past
bro I've been accused by girls as being
a robot you know of like not having any
feelings I'm like I'm a [ __ ] human
being I got feelings other buddies girl
didn't start cutting themselves in front
just so you think you feel something no
it's not that I don't feel anything it's
just that you know they want it
expressed in a certain way and it's and
it was like not too easy think them over
to me dude they would have got
everything they need it is 18 year old
David they would have loved it
[ __ ] did you start a pop locking
on the floor end of the spectrum it's
too overbearing I felt like you though
when I broke up with my last girlfriend
Khalif literally came in afterwards
after I just broke up with her on the
phone and I was like I said what's up
man how you doing
are you hungry cause like he wasn't even
down honey I just broke up with her you
like damn you okay I'm like I'm good
yeah you know what I'm just I'm not to
admit something I've never admitted
before okay okay you gonna [ __ ]
you're gonna you got to lose a lot of
respect for me you lose a lot of respect
at me or you're gonna respect me alone
okay so when I was going to break up
with her mhm at this point I had already
cemented it cemented in my heart that
she wasn't the one for me and I was okay
with it yes yeah so when I told her like
it was over I could hear her kind of
crying on the other end
I felt so bad of her because I didn't
feel anything I sort of faked crying for
her fake crying for her I felt so bad I
didn't feel anything
oh so high-end I've literally put on my
acting cat and I was like ever sold this
[ __ ] this is a little embarrassing I
must be getting older cuz I don't give a
[ __ ] but I matter now started fake
crying because I felt so bad for her so
I didn't I wanted her I didn't want her
to feel like as if when I walked away
that I was a completely heartless human
being but I and I kind of deflected on
um I guess you would say that I kind of
blamed it on the fact that she like Wade
cheated on me huh but that really wasn't
it it was it was it was more like we
just we didn't have it it just piled on
top of that you know and look there's
nothing wrong with that though it's like
honestly doing that is not a disservice
to somebody well I mean I'm not talking
about the fake crying thing I'm talking
about ending the relationship
ending the relationship you're doing a
service because you're you're saving
each other time you're saving each other
energy it's like look it's not working
I'm perfectly clear about that and I'm
fine she found somebody else that'll
fire her yeah but the fake crime I don't
know if it helped her yeah I thought it
would help her because okay yeah but
would it be that I just break up with
her I'm like it is over right uh nice to
see you at least okay at least it's stem
from like a pure place of like you know
you had compassion comments below I want
to know if you think that would you
rather have a guy just be heartless
about the break-up bet you [ __ ] love
or would you at least want to have the
guy show some emotion oh here's the
thing though here's the thing is that if
you are just kind of firm in your stance
about it and I make it clear and there's
not much emotion involved it's like well
[ __ ] as heartbroken as I am this [ __ ] is
over you know but then it's like phew
you're heartless bro I care I care even
I have to remember all the good times
that we had and I and I'll tell you this
dude she couldn't tell that I was faking
to cry though that's how your boy won
the Sundance baby oh now that cried man
I cry my [ __ ] heart out dude and I
just never ending that phone call a
little embarrassed to myself just like
Maz with all said is super nice
I had to do the fake rifle but hey you
know what though if it helped her then
great right it served its purpose I
guess at least it was coming from a pure
place yeah yeah at least it wasn't like
you know you're so super just trying to
emulate human feelings to relate yeah
you're just like oh she must be going
through it I'm gonna I'm gonna give her
something dude I'm gonna give her
something she was a little upset though
because I remember later on she texted
me and how she felt about it and not
about the fake crying because she didn't
know she didn't know yeah but I but she
said that she wished that I had broken
up with her in person then over the
phone but I was kind of distance I'm
gonna spend $200 to come break up with
you right right yeah I don't think I
could have faked right in front of you a
person yeah no I mean look man I death
that's something I generally agree with
is that you know if you're capable of
doing it in person for a breakup or even
having a serious conversation about the
relationship you should do a
face-to-face but when you're dealing in
long-term it's like it's not as
practical you know and it's like let's
save both of ourselves some time some
money and traveling and just [ __ ] do
this the practical way yeah man the [ __ ]
but the crying highly podcast where you
guys think very low of me no he's open
he opens up his chest for you to see yep
but yeah you guys can catch the genius
brain podcast every Thursday in Sundays
I told you a lot of this [ __ ] is deep
[ __ ] but sometimes it's dumb as [ __ ] I'm
an I'm a stand-up comic first baby I'll
help you guys on your day problems and
you can find edrick at ed to Instagram
everything else and of course check out
SCR TS o CI ET y dot-com secret society
yes sir
or the clothing brand man you guys would
love that [ __ ] cop and his [ __ ] dope
was probably part of my everyday
wardrobe you know what's up and we'll
see y'all next time
all right show up peace peace